allez allez sympa mais simplement c'est
pas la fille mais c'est pas une fille
qui va te calmer c'est sûr
Coolio la dernière fois qu'on s'est vu
sur ce plateau vous étiez en compagnie
de Leslie du loft
c'est comment ça se fait que vous soyez
plus avec elle
ce qui s'est passé c'est que
tous les deux on avait des forces
personnalités on dit un peu trop cinglé
tous les deux elle est complètement
cinglé moi aussi et donc un peu trop
cinglé tous les deux ça a pas marché un
peu trop non non
elle est elle est vraiment
bien sympa bien cool mais c'est
une force personnalité c'est une forte
tête et pour moi j'aime bien que les
femmes la ferment un petit peu j'aime
bien pouvoir dire à ma gonzesse écoute
tu t'assiella tu l'as fermes tu la
boucles et il faut simplement qu'elle
m'écoute un peu plus mais uniquement
quand j'ai raison il faut qu'elle
m'écoute quand j'ai raison quand même
mais elle m'écoutez pas impossible
jamais sinon n'écoutez jamais me
chercher une bière et bougez pas
donc partir de ce moment-là notre
relation a commencé à virer un peu
devenir un peu volatile on va dire et
moi je me suis dit que peut-être on
allait sombrer dans la violence donc il
était temps de d'arrêter mais on est
toujours bien ami on discute c'est ce
qu'il a dit peut-être peut-être on a les
sombrer dans la violence elle était un
peu comme ça là ouais ouais
il était pas loin de lui mettre tu vois
c'est arrêter le net hein juste avant de
sombrer dans la violence non il faut
bien voir quand même taper un peu sur
les nerfs bon j'ai jamais tapé dessus
non plus hein c'est vrai mais bon j'ai
des enfants aussi mais bon
je pense pas vraiment que ce soit une
vraie mère elle est plutôt intéressée
par sa carrière son avenir et s'en sort
bien euh des chansons elle fait plein de
Colli vous avez plus de contact avec
Leslie du lot c'est fini maintenant vous
vous appelez jamais non non on est
encore en contact on a encore en contact
donc ça nous arrive
et donc
c'est pas la fille c'est pas une fille
qui va te calmer c'est sûr mais il faut
un type qui soit vraiment une mauvette
elle a besoin d'une mauviette c'est ça
l'antenne
allez
c'est pas vieux 50 ans
qui est plus durer quelqu'un qui soit
plus patient plus patient que moi en
tout cas parce que moi je suis pas
patient du tout et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater
vous et mettez un pouce bleu